précédemment dans le bureau d les jambes
avant guillaume de bailly que vous
connaissez mieux sous le nom de malotrus
d'auckland et qui vient de finir sa
mission en syrie
ou comment vous appeliez là-bas dans le
febvre vous avez été amené à rompre
certaines relations qui ont pu être
assez forte image et madame nadia
mansour
les white s'occupe du prochain plan d
importance notre mission c'est de
connaître les gens sans vous faire
remarquer peut être dangereux le
syndrome du clandestin qui est avancé
masqué
ce qu'a fait monsieur bailly a mis
beaucoup de personnes dans des
situations de danger extrême
il doit rendre des comptes pour cela
le truc n'a pas fait beaucoup d'efforts
pour se cacher
la russie est un sanctuaire pour lui je
comprends pas que vous soyez pas en
prison ça vaut que jolie de ces
détentions jeu vient d'être nommé
directeur de la d6 l'un de mes agents va
faire une enquête poussée
musique sous couvert d'un audit de
fonctionnement ici le centre 21 le
centre de recherche en intelligence
artificielle
j'ai suggéré à de bailly de proposer au
fsb de recrutement d'un jeune guilhounet
sylvari l'aiment show time pourquoi
c'est pas tout et qui par ce que je sais
faire ils savent le faire aussi il ya
plein de trucs que je sais faire et qui
savent pas faire
c'est vendu aux américains maintenant il
se vend aux russes ce pipe est un très
gros travail pour nous et nous assassine
vous venez de revivre les saisons
précédentes du bureau des légendes
découvrez la saison 5 inédite lundi 6
avril seulement sur canal+